لي
له الصوت الجريح ينزف اخر انفاسه بعد ان
انهكه الصراع الطويل مع المرض عبد الكريم
عبد القادر صوت الكويت الحنون يغادر
احبائه من العشاق بعد سته عقود كامله من
العطاء
ولد الفنان القدير ذات يوم من عام
بمدينه الزبير
اجبت وداني
الطفوله الصعبه صقلت احاسيسه طويلا قبل ان
تبرز موهبته التي جذبت اكبر الملحنين
والشعراء في الكويت والخليج
امضى العشرينيات من شبابه ينشد الموشحات
الدينيه في الوقت الذي شغل وظائف بوزاره
الداخليه الا ان موهبته المتفرده انفجرت
وعجلت بتفرغه للغناء ليصبح اكبر سفير
للاغنيه الكويتيه ومنها السر قلوب عشاقه
في كل الخليج
قلبي
ابو خالد فنان لا يشبه غيره اذ بقي وفيا
لاسلوبه الفني وادائه الملتزم ولم ترافق
اغنياته اعذب الالحان بل كانت قصصا للعشاق
طوال اكثر من نصف قرن
[موسيقى]
غادر عبد الكريم عبد القادر الاغنيه
الكويتيه والخليجيه عن عمر فاق ال 80
ربيعا تاركا وراءه ارثا فنيا ضخما سيحفظ
اسمه ما بقي الفن الاصيل
من الفرقه
احيا
واموت لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات